[Music]
so again I'm Sahana I'm a graduate
student at Stanford info lab and today
I'm going to be talking about a system
that we've been developing it's called
macro Basin it's a system for if I
basically attacked as a search engine
over your fast data streams and can
everyone hear me okay just yes okay
great so this is a joint work with a
huge number of incredible individuals
and if you're interested in learning
more about this project after the talk
or if you have any questions for me or
the team in general you can feel free to
reach us at micro base at C s dot
stanford.edu so many of us have spent
the last couple of days here really due
to this huge increase in data that we've
been seeing over the last few years and
in fact at least in a near foreseeable
future we expect our data volumes to
double every two years this is really
because we've developed and capitalized
on our ability to measure and collect
this fine-grained information about all
the complex systems around us and
coupled with the rise of new big data
systems are seeing that we now have the
infrastructure to store collect and
retain all of this data in in fashion
it's cheaper than ever so the result we
see that major technology companies
today Microsoft Facebook Twitter
Linkedin Google what have you they
already report collecting over 12
million events per second today and now
what these companies want to do with all
of this data is figure out how they can
use it to monitor and uncover key
insights into their underlying system
behavior now what the current monitoring
pipelines look like what our current
systems that actually use things like
this look like we'll go through a toy
example to get a feel for that so first
data is typically generated from some
automated process this might be sensor
data video feeds data center telemetry
what-have-you from here this data is
then collected and processed into forms
very easy to work with just turning it
into some canonical data format again
this is pretty standard
after discs we send all of this
processed data into a sort of database
or data warehouse for a permanent
storage as well as a feed to a data
visualization tools and monitoring
dashboards so that our users and data
scientists can actually figure out
what's going on with these systems at
least at a high level typically over
this layer you then have simple trash
will based rules and predicates and
alerts in place to make sure
think to crazy is going on and when
something crazy does happen when an
alert is fired when a rule is fired when
something goes wrong or I guess in a
typical use case you just get a bunch of
angry emails from your users you have to
call your data scientists or engineers
on call to figure out so they can sit
down and take a look at this data take a
look at these alerts and try and debug
to figure out what's going on in this
monitoring use case now perhaps
surprisingly what we found by talking to
a number of companies using pipelines
very similar to this less than 6 percent
of their data is ever actually being
used for any sort of reactive analyses
and this seemed very strange to us
fundamentally you ready because here you
have all these companies collecting 12
million events for a second right it's a
lot of data all of your poly collecting
millions and millions of data points for
a second but only a 6% of it has ever
actually looked at or is ever being used
which seemed to be kind of a problem why
is it that all of you are collecting all
this information and not making full use
of it and more importantly we want to
know is can we use the answer to this
question to figure out how we can enable
more proactive ideally automated
analyses over this data to automatically
figure out what's going on in our
monitor in our data sets or telemetry
they answer this question we actually
first begin by analyzing those current
workflows that I showed you before to
figure out what's actually going on what
the key bottleneck is and we realize
that human attention is what's actually
fundamentally limited here and it's just
a fact that human attention is scarce
you can't expect humans to go in there
and take a look at every single data
point that's coming in seems pretty
obvious but now let's take a back take a
look back at the monitoring pipeline I
showed you and take let's take a look at
what concrete engineering solutions are
actually in place at each and every
stage of this pipeline first thing you
might notice when you look at this is
that well there's no shortage in system
in systems for collecting storing
querying visualizing and all there's
really no shortage in these data flow
engines that can do this but when you
get to that final mile at that point
where you really need a human in the
loop to figure out what's going on you
realize that there really aren't very
many gold standard systems in place that
allow you to do this and this is exactly
where that attention bottleneck I talked
about before really manifests itself
right there's nothing to help our
end-user our data analyst
Engineers on call to figure out what's
going on in these systems so data flow
proof engines provide a means of you
know processing and figuring out what's
going on but they're not enough they
don't tell you what to show to your
humans they don't tell you what
functions to run so what functions do we
run right what what what does cut it
clearly your standard select project and
join religious are not enough something
that most of you who might be thinking
of in your heads like well why don't we
just go to the statistics community your
machine learning community they have
tons of high-level functions that we can
run for classification explanation
what-have-you but again for any of you
who have actually tried to implement
these in practice you've probably
realized that very few of them are even
available up front for you to use and
even fewer of those are actually
implemented and battle-tested the scale
that you're interested in running in
right it's very very difficult to get
this actually working so what we realize
we really needed and what was really
missing from this workflow is a system
that composes these efficient high-level
statistical operators to form to analog
of select project and join where for
fast data analytics instead and more
importantly we want these functions and
these these systems to enable users to
easily make use of these operators and
as painless away as possible and that's
exactly what we've been trying to build
at Stanford so we're trying to so while
the engines from before that I talked
about provide the sort of low-level
interface that allows you to build up
these data processing pipelines
Macrobius tries to operate at this next
level of abstraction where what we're
really trying to do is have macro base
just suck in all the data that it comes
in from all these initial pipeline
stages and figure out well exactly how
can our use enable our users to
basically compose these pipelines in a
much more easy way by providing a
toolkit for these efficient higher level
of statistical operators so concretely
again macro base is a monitoring engine
that's designed to prioritize human
attention by using statistical operators
specifically in the form of efficient
classification and explanation operators
together with streaming data flow and in
the remainder of this talk I'm going to
continue talking about some of our goals
as well as the architecture enables us
and some of our early results were going
in
so I initially actually had a live demo
to show you but due to technical
difficulties I won't be able to actually
go through it so I'll just talk about
the scenario show you how how the demo
might have gone and then if you're
interested in learning more to actually
see it in person you can come to my
office hours afterwards so to scenario I
want you to keep in mind through this
kind of pseudo demo is that you're a
mobile developer and you just release a
new application into the wild and you're
trying to figure out if your application
is performing as intended across all of
the different devices that you're that
you're running on you're now receiving
reports that indicate a subset of our
users are experiencing higher battery
train and others and you're not really
sure what's causing this or who's
actually experiencing this high battery
draining but you want to see if you can
figure out why and what the demo would
have stepped us through would be how you
can actually use macro base to figure
this out and what I would have showed
you would have actually been the macro
based user interface which is typically
the first point of contact that most
users have with the macro key system and
how you would actually end up using the
system is to first know if that screen
shot is too small so first what you
would do is actually input the bait the
data set of interest which I have right
there is kind of the sample mobile data
on CSV file from there when you hit
enter and what macro base is going to do
is populate um a list
demonstrating all of the columns of
interest all the columns present in that
dataset so here you have for instance
your app version average temperature
battery drain and so on as I mentioned
in the DUT in the demo scenario before
we're looking for devices that are
experiencing higher battery drained and
others so all I would do here if when
I'm using macro basis select high
battery drain as kind of the metric of
interest from there I want to figure out
well what attributes are correlated with
this high battery for instance it might
be specific application versions that
are experiencing high battery drain or a
specific firmware versions Hardware make
hardware model and so on so you want to
figure out well are any of these
different attributes correlated with
high battery drain you then hit enter
and within a typically less than a
second macro base will actually return
results to you in this format we're what
macro base does is it shows you that for
devices matching a specific hardware
make hard
model and app version those data points
are actually going to be what I have
there if I can can't do that okay what I
have here is that okay so what I have
here is it actually here actually is
that on these devices of the specific
hardware make model and app version are
400 times more likely to be an outlier
than not and I've had hit explore I can
take a look at the actual distribution
of points return my macro base and I see
here that the data points matching this
combination over here is much higher
than the normal base population here in
blue so a macro base module would be
your so macro base is actually able to
return a number of these results and
then show you these kind of in real time
so you can take a look at the actual
results that you have now as an example
of a more concrete result that we have
attained by running this exact same
pipeline over an actual data set is that
in collaboration with Cambridge mobile
telematics so CMT is a is a company that
provides a a mobile application that
records driving behavior over time and
what they're really trying to do is use
user driving behavior to figure out if
they can provide actionable insight into
how you can improve driving safety and
driving behavior and the question they
had for us was well how can we tell if
our application is actually performing
properly across all of the different
types of devices and models and
operating systems that were running on
again very similar to the demo I would
have showed you earlier now why is this
challenging why is it that CMT came to
us to see if we could help them answer
this question a little easier well to
begin with just within the Android
ecosystem alone there are over 25
different major API releases across
24,000 different Android devices and the
real challenge here is that spending
even one second to look at every single
one of these combinations is gonna take
you as a user 7 entire days and that's
it that's all you're doing no eating no
sleeping nothing gonna take you seven
days to just look at every single
combination by running the data set
through macro base we could actually
identify a bug in their data center in
their application that we could then
verify with their engineers namely that
a specific beta version
i OS had a buggy bluetooth stock which
meant that their their CMT devices
actually couldn't connect to these iOS
devices and again just by running macro
base we could identify this in orders of
magnitude last time that it would have
taken an actual user to sift through and
figure out what's going on so now that
we have gone over kind of how you might
interact with the macro basis to Matt a
high-level and some basic results I'm
gonna go into how macro base actually
enables is sort of the sort of records
analysis as well as some more advanced
usage beyond the user interface I just
showed you so as I discussed previously
macro base was designed as a system that
cascades these statistical operators to
enable efficient monitoring and
operators that we realize it would be
most useful for our tasks are actually
operators at transform segments and then
aggregate our data streams so first give
an incoming data set macro base
transforms this data into a form that's
easier to work with for future pipeline
stages from there the transform data
isn't passed into the classification
stage of a macro base pipeline and all
we're trying to do here is segment out
our data into various classes so that we
can then identify an explanation stage
well what actually what what are the key
factors a differentiate different
classes from one another what makes a
data point an outlier versus an in liar
and I'm going to take some time now to
go into each and every single one of
these operators in more detail so first
transformation transformation is
actually an optional step in the macro
based pipeline as I mentioned earlier
all we're really trying to do is find a
way to encode domain or application
specific behavior into our pipeline for
instance if you have a time series data
set we have operators that allow you to
compute Fourier transforms that were
your data on the other hand if you have
image specific data you might want to
compute your q or luminosity over this
data instead and pass these in as
features to future Packer based pipeline
stages and the whole thinking the idea
behind these kind of simple
transformation steps is that you can
then compose them efficiently above one
another to make more complex features
out of your out of your data
the next class of operators I'm going to
talk about are the classification
operators and here all we're really
trying to do again is segment and filter
out my data based on different target
behavior for instance I want to find
data that's behaving abnormally from the
rest by default what we do is provide
users with a set of classification
operators that identify data it's just
unlikely to occur so this might be
something simple
based on unsupervised entity estimation
based techniques for instance this can
be a cruelly incredibly simple like fit
a Gaussian over a data if my data points
are more than K it's near deviations
away from I mean just flag it as an
outlier this could be slightly more
complex than that as well and that you
could fit an actual density over your
days your just your data points using
kernel density estimation and again you
get this PDF over your data and you can
figure out what's lying in my tails of
the distribution mark doses being
outliers and you can then you can then
combine these with actual with other
attacks as well such as I'm with
thresholds going back to the battery
example I had before you might want to
mark all the data points exhibiting
batteries Rhian greater than 50% is
being an outlier so you can hardcore
that into the microwave system you can
also do predicate based classification
where for instance you might want to
mark all data points that came in today
as being an outlier and all data points
that came in from previous days it's
being normal and in liars and you just
want to figure out what's different
between them okay and finally we come to
the explanation operators here what we
want to do is just take the data that
comes in as a result as the cut of the
classification stage and figure out what
really differentiates these different
classes from one another we want to
figure out what behavior is highly
correlated with being filtered or with
being classified if you take a look at
the two data streams I have here
formatting got a little weird and the
two data streams I have here you see
that in both the error and non in your
error scenarios iPhone 7 8 and 10 are
all present in kind of similar amounts
on the other hand if you take a look at
the countries you're gonna have to take
my word for the part that got cut off
you take a look at the countries Canada
is actually only present in the error
date effect not in the in lying data set
and so that's indicates that you might
want to go ahead and take a closer look
at Canada to figure out what's going on
there because there seems to be
something that's correlated with being
an error we quantify this much
with what's known as the risk ratio it's
commonly found in epidemiology and all
it really does it's tell it tells me how
much more likely am I to be an outlier
if I'm from Canada versus if I'm not so
again if you look at it from the example
from the previous slide what I would
receive here is under scratchy o-5 which
indicates that I'm five times more
likely to be an outlier if I'm from
Canada versus if I'm not and by
affection efficiently checking this risk
ratio over a number of different
attributes we're able to pinpoint a
specific subset of attributes that are
highly correlated with being an outlier
versus not being an outlier okay kind of
completes our whirlwind tour of the
macro based transform classify and
explain architecture and so now I'm
going to go into some more advanced
usage and how people can interact with
the system so earlier what I showed you
or what I would have showed you is the
kind of basic user interface at macro
base provides this is the most simple
point-and-click UI that users typically
have is their first point of contact
with the macro Bay system this is how
they kind of take their batch data and
figure out if macro means is something
that they want to continue working with
I keep talking about these statistical
operators we do have more operators than
what are what's provided in the user
interface in the UI we kind of just have
the most basic bare minimum someone
might want to use if you want to make
use of the other transforms that we have
or other operators we have like the
Fourier transform operations and such
you can put together your own pipelines
in Java to do so and finally for the
more adventurous you can actually build
your own custom data flow operators and
hook these up with the microbe a system
Java or C++ and you can just stick it in
and use it just as you would our own in
addition to make it easier to hook into
additional monitoring pipelines we
actually provide a JSON REST API so how
that works is first you just select your
input data again similar to the UI just
you're an infidel CSV file the metrics
that you want to classify over the
attributes that you want to group the
classified metrics by and finally the
metrics that you want to use to explain
your data over here again it's the risk
ratio and we have a few users that are
able to use this to kind of directly
hook into their
pipelines and dashboards and an exciting
area of active research for us it's
actually to pour macro base to a sequel
compatible or sequel like interface just
because we find that most data science
works those the kind of first way of
interacting with the data tends to be
with a sequel like set of rules and
syntax so here we have again all you
have to do is select your input again
very similar to before just a table that
you're interested in working with how
you want to transform your data so for
instance here I'm looking at my battery
drain and I want to look at like the
percentiles over my battery drain I can
define classification operators over
this what I have here is that I want to
mark all data points being in the top 5%
as my data is being an outlier finally
you can group by the different
attributes of interest and explained by
the risk ratio that I mentioned before
again the flow is very similar across
the different API is but it's just some
formats are easier to integrate what
they're easier to use with than others
all right so again like I mentioned I've
been talking about these statistical
operators over and over and over again
but what do these actually look like and
what does it take to actually build some
of these I'm now going to talk they can
take some time talking about some of our
recent results and mainly in the form of
how we've been building out new
efficient macro based operators and even
if these specific optimizations aren't
necessarily relevant to the exact tasks
that you have I think the highest level
takeaway from this section is just
really kind of the insights that we use
with said just because we had this
combinatorial explosion in our data or
search space that doesn't necessarily
mean you to do an equal amount of work
in order to process this data right so
taking advantage of your data and tuning
to your task at hand can actually enable
significantly better performance while
without sacrificing any statistical
statistical performance so the first
class of operators that we optimize were
in a dimension however the
transformation operators and
specifically what we focused on was
dimensionality reduction so
dimensionality reduction is actually
it's just they form a core class of
techniques for most data analytics
pipelines and principal component
analysis or PCA is one of the key
techniques that people use to run
dimensionality reduction
unfortunately most out-of-the-box
implementations of PCA are incredibly
slow in fact in the worst case you might
find something that uses a singular
value decomposition under the hood
that's gonna take forever to run turns
out that by using two key insights were
actually we can enable significantly
faster performance in practice even over
these naive PC Ava SVD operations and
first of all we realized that many data
sources that we're looking at many data
sources that are being generated now are
incredibly highly structured and
repetitive for instance we take a look
at the two time series they're they're
very clear modes present in your data
and you can kind of see that you don't
need to actually use all of the pure
data in order to capture all of the
variants in it what this means is that
we can actually sample our data
aggressively before before fitting our
model without losing information the
question now is well how much do i
sample if I don't say if I sample to a
few data points I'm not gonna actually
capture all the information in my data
on the other hand if I sample too many
data points I'm not really going to get
the certificate of computational
benefits of running on a sample to begin
with so to guide the search if really
how much should i sample we realized
that dimensionality reduction is
actually a data pre-processing step what
this means is that you typically don't
want to be spending more time
pre-processing your data than running
the actual task itself so all we really
did was start with a small sample of our
dataset and incrementally increase in
sample and increasingly larger subsample
of our data until it just becomes too
expensive to continue doing so just by
doing this like the simple sampling
until until you've seen enough we're
actually able to enable 50 times speed
ups in dimensionality reduction and over
33 times speed ups in intend pipelines
compare it to PCM is VT and again we
just looked at the data properties with
hand and sampled aggressively based on
that you can imagine doing some sort of
clustering in advance depending on
whatever your data looks like and
running all of your pipeline steps and
these kind of these little examples
instead so we've also applied
optimizations to classification
operators in Macrobius also we first
focused on kernel density estimation and
all KDE is is a technique that can look
at your input data and give you a
distribution over your data points and
how it works is that for each incoming
data point you basic
assigning a little about this could be
like a little Gaussian bump like in the
images I have there and as these data
points come in you're going to
incrementally build up your probability
density function over your data points
given this PDF you can then figure out
regions of low density and mark these
points as being outliers or inliers
as you might guess similar to pca KDE is
actually incredibly slow to run naively
over five hundred thousand points is
going to take you two hours on a modern
CPU and the question again is what can
we do better is there some way that we
can speed up the performance of KDE for
our specific classification tasks and
turns out again yes we can and all we
really use to exploit was the fact that
we're really only using kernel density
estimation for classification
unlike most typical uses of KDE we don't
really need that fine-grained
representation of our distribution all I
really want to know is if is my point in
an area of low density space or high
density space so I can classify it as
being an outlier or not
so just by realizing this we can
actually prune out a lot of the
computation necessary for running KDE
and obtain over two orders of magnitude
speed-up compared to running just a
naive KDE that you might find out of the
box and again here we would just look
using the task at hand to provide
specific error bounds over to the tests
that we're looking at and prune out all
unnecessary computation based on that so
this can kind of be applied to a number
of different other other tasks that
we're looking at now
that's supposed to be moving okay and so
finally we've been creating new
operations for efficient explanation and
in this case we've really focused on
time-series visualization just because
we see it in a lot of monitoring tasks a
lot of people have these incredibly
noisy time series data sets that are
incredibly difficult to read for
instance looking at this here it's
unclear what's actually going on it
turns out that by smoothing your data
set with something as simple as a simple
moving average where you just kind of
average out your data points over time
you can get a significantly better and
easier to read representation of your
time series without while still
maintaining the salient features of your
original of your original time series
the challenge here though is how can you
actually automatically choose these
smoothing parameters so given your
original doing noisy data set if you
smooth too much you're not only going to
smooth out the noise but also the
higher-level features that are present
in your time series so it's unclear how
you might want to cherry choose these
all the different parameters that you
can to smooth out your data set as
efficiently as possible
if you smooth this original data set
correctly you can actually see here that
not only do you see the high level trend
the overall average but you also see
these long term deviations that are
greater than the noise as well so you
can see these little peaks and trials in
your original data set so how do we
automatically choose this I'm gonna omit
some of the details and just say that by
formulating this as an optimization
problem where we're trying to firmly
smooth as much as possible while
preserving long-term distance our
long-term deviations we can effectively
search the parameter space very quickly
and automatically determine what the
best smoothing parameters are for a time
series data set with a few quick
examples of the kind of results that we
see what I have here is a time series
time series dataset representing the
number of taxicab pickups and drop-offs
over a time period in New York by
applying this technique we're actually
able to see a clear dip in our time
series which corresponds to the holiday
season actually Thanksgiving where it
was a very clear dip in taxi cab
drop-offs and pickups during that time
period similarly if you look at this
noisy time series FRA that represents
the average temperature in England over
a couple of hundred years just by
running our ASAP smoothing technique
over it we actually can say very clear
trend
in our data and even in the very end you
kind of see this uptick corresponding to
global warming
and we actually have a live demo running
at all times at future data that's in
4wd with such a SAP again this link
should be posted later on for you to
take a look and play with and again here
all we did was we had this huge sample
space and we really looked at the tasks
and constraints and the different things
that we had on hand to probe our sample
space efficiently and figure out how we
can navigate through as quickly as
possible without actually running all
the computation across all of these
different um all these different
configurations now with a sample of some
of the work that we're doing if you're
interested in learning more we do have a
blog I'll flash just slide again towards
the end and you can take a look at some
of the different papers and the work
that we've been doing if you're
interested in learning more all right so
now just wrapping up what's next for the
macro based project well first of all
many systems that most people have pre
aggregate their data into these data
cubes just because storing all of this
raw data regardless of how cheap all of
this new infrastructure is it's still
not quite cheap enough to just store
robot items so natural extension for
macro base is figuring out well how do
we apply all of these operators to
operate on pre aggregated data or data
cubes instead for instance if all we
have is access to means and standard
deviation and moments and things like
that we're also looking into how we can
create more efficient sketching
algorithms to more efficiently compute
these differences between different
classes we're focusing down with a time
series similarity search in
visualization literature specifically
applied now to finding low magnitude
earthquakes which are actually
incredibly difficult to find converging
noise for instance how can you pull out
repeated noise from your sprinkler
firing every couple of seconds versus
having an actual like low magnitude
earthquake concern we're also looking
into how we can automate the feature
selection process specifically in the
demo that I would have showed you
earlier you actually had to click which
metrics you're interested in working
with can we automate that in some way
and how can we deal with hierarchical
data sources a lot of the data sources
that people could come with form natural
hierarchies for instance you have
country state city things like that or
data center cluster node how can you
more efficiently optimize your queries
and run your computation quickly so that
you can automatically determine which
features a user might be interested in
working with and
we're also looking into how we can more
efficiently perform temporal difference
attention just differentiating different
time periods from one region to another
so just to recap we're seeing this huge
increase in need for tools that will
help prioritize human attention in these
sorts of monitoring and analytic
workflows current data flow engines
really aren't enough for the task at
hand and neither are kind of a standard
out of the box machine learning in
statistics operators so our proposal is
actually to create a pipeline that
combines these highly efficient optimum
highly optimized operators for future
extraction classification explanation
and end-to-end data pipeline so that we
can make it as easy and painless to
monitor our datasets as possible if
you're interested in taking a look at
how this actually works to get your
hands dirty and actually try it out you
can find all of our work and all of our
code online on github if you just search
for macro base you should be able to
find it and again all of our work we all
have a blog post or all if I work as
well as you don't want to sift through
academic papers go ahead and take a look
at our blog post to see what we're
working on thank you hi what language
was used and why so right now we're
provide the base operators are all in
Java just because it was easier to
integrate with existing users who are
who have kind of their pipelines already
built in that we're looking into we have
a subset of operators now ported to C++
the sequel interface for instance is all
backed by C++ code and in the future
we're looking into providing like a kind
of psychic learning type Python wrapper
around it but that's kind of much in the
future so by downsampling your data
happily you might risk of missing some
important a peculiarities yeah exactly
so how that project actually works is
that you have some so also encoded into
your your problem is this notion of how
accurate is your transformation for
instance if you're looking to preserve
pairwise distances you might want to
compute your pairwise distances in your
transformed space just to make sure that
you haven't deviated too far from the
original original space the kind of
quality checking as you go is also
performed
kind of how you see if you're done
sampling or not mm-hmm two questions
first of all am i right that your tool
will allow me to do anomaly detection on
like server response time so if i have
an api service and suddenly response
times are going actually it can alert me
the alerts so we don't provide the
alerting out-of-the-box so that's gonna
have it'll take some engineering kind of
on your and to hook this all together we
kind of just provide the underlying
algorithms that you can then pass on to
your loading software from from my
experience the less the engineering team
has to do the better so yeah it's not a
hard thing to dad so i think about that
and the other is so let's say i as a
data scientist have detected the anomaly
i go and do the search and you oh look
there's you know certain set of updates
that are much higher latency than others
mm-hmm
how easy is it for me to get the data
set that produced those pictures in my
favorite format so i can start analyzing
it myself yeah so right now we actually
only have are the only users that we've
the users that we've had that i've
wanted that sort of functionality just
wanted to CSV dump that's all we provide
by default it shouldn't be too difficult
to construct conductors to do so though
for any format that you're interested in
okay because that's like once I don't
want to be trapped inside your system to
do the analysis oh yeah so right now by
default we dump everything out of the
CSV file yeah
so to what extent is this a a streaming
system is something that doesn't look at
all other day - it looks at recent data
for a particular time horizon and your
examples seem to be looking at like an
infinite time horizon can you talk about
how how much state is involved in the
system how could you choose what is the
right time horizon yeah so basically
this all depends on the specific use
case at hand right now we assume that
our users are kind of giving us a time
window that are interested in looking
with all of our actual applications that
are in production right now aren't they
typically operate over mini but just so
you say I want to look at a window size
of this amount and then we're just
configured to update our are basically
data structures in mini batches of that
size we have been tad at truly a user
who's actually wanted a truly truly
streaming this case yet this and said
mini batches tend to suffice answer your
question yeah I think I think so
I mean it's kind of interesting that
they they say that you know if you're
doing analytics you you're not
interested in numbers you're only
interested in ratios because the value
of 100 might be high for one thing and
low for another thing yes you're
assuming so you need to you need to look
at history to figure out what the what
the nominal value is precisely and then
apply a window of a recent recent data
to see how that's deviated from the long
term long term yeah those are all
configurable parameters for now
[Music]